[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à tous très heureuse de
vous retrouver sur Public Sénat
saviez-vous que le monde ne tourne pas
rond pour tout le monde un Français sur
10 pense que la terre est plate si on
s'intéresse à la génération Z ça serait
même si jeune Français sur 10 qui
adhèrent au théories platistes et oui
c'est comme ça que ça s'appelle de quoi
conclure un divorce entre les jeunes et
les sciences ces jeunes qui sont très
attirés en parallèle par l'occultisme ou
encore l'astrologie s si simple dans
avoir 20 ans on va s'intéresser aux
raisons de cette défiance mais aussi
nuancée ce tableau car les jeunes sont
aussi plus nombreux que leurs aînés à
croire la parole scientifique quand on
parle par exemple du climat et sur son
plateau j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir
Gaëlle Fortin bonjour alors vous avez 25
ans vous venez de Bobigny vous aviez
fait des études de biologie et vous êtes
aujourd'hui doctorants en cancérologie à
Paris vous êtes aussi vulgarisateur
scientifique sur les réseaux sociaux
avec votre chaîne Youtube la biologie
mais aussi dans les collèges et les
lister merci beaucoup d'être avec nous à
côté de vous j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir romane Komo bonjour vous
avez 23 ans vous venez de Lyon vous êtes
alternante dans la communication et vous
tenez un compte TikTok va simple c'est
comme ça qu'on dit près de 700000
abonnés vous suivent suivre vos conseils
qui portent sur l'astrologie ou encore
le pouvoir des pierres la lithothérapie
également sur ce plateau deux experts
nous accompagnent tout au long de cette
émission Matteo matagora bonjour vous
êtes directeur de la médiation
scientifique et de l'éducation à univers
science univers sciences c'est
l'établissement qui rassemble la Cité
des sciences et de l'industrie et le
Palais de la Découverte à Paris
universion ce qui a récemment publié son
deuxième baromètre de l'esprit critique
qui analyse notamment le rapport des
Français aux sciences et enfin pour
compléter ce plateau j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir Rudy reichstad bonjour vous
êtes un membre de l'Observatoire des
radicalités politiques à la Fondation
Jean Jaurès vous êtes le fondateur de
conspiration watch un site qui œuvre à
démonter les infox les théories
conspirationnistes ce qui vous a
d'ailleurs valu d'être vous-même l'objet
de menaces de campagne de dénigrement
sur le web et vous racontez tout cela
dans votre livre qui vient de paraître
au cœur du complot chez Grasset je parle
également de votre précédent livre qui
portait sur un sujet qui nous intéresse
qui s'appelle l'opium des imbéciles
alors démonter les contre-vérités
scientifiques et les théories du complot
c'est justement la mission que c'est
donner Samuel Buisseret ce Belge mieux
connu sous le nom de Mister Sam sur les
réseaux et pourtant tomber dans la
marmite du complotisme quand il était
tout petit alors pourquoi fait-il
aujourd'hui du développement de l'esprit
critique son combat Samia de chir la
rencontre regardez
servira de portes d'entrée à beaucoup
d'autres dans cet univers
conspirationniste il devient lui-même
prosélyte je me rappelle je voulais
faire des des soirées où je m'étais sur
les murs les articles que j'avais trouvé
pour essayer d'éveiller les consciences
c'est toujours c'est toujours ce même
mécanisme on sait quelque chose que les
gens ne savent pas sur un groupe de
puissants qui contrôle le monde ou qui
ont un dessin pour le monde et nous on a
la mission d'aller éveiller les autres
mais en 2015 le décès d'un de ses
proches va provoquer un déclic à 32 ans
ils ont totalement avec l'univers
complotiste pour rejoindre une autre
communauté celle des sceptiques un
virage à 180 degrés
aujourd'hui âgé d'une quarantaine
d'années il anime désormais une chaîne
Youtube curieuse et curieux bonjour 27
avril 2020 le Pentagone décide
d'officialiser un trio de vidéo de OVNI
qui avait été liqué quelques années
auparavant confirmant donc l'origine des
objets filmés comme non identifié sur
Internet Samuel Buisseret devient Mister
San un débunker c'est à dire une
personne qui tente de démonter les
théories du complot parce qu'il est
lui-même été complotiste il sait que
chercher à les convaincre serait
contre-productif il tente donc de rester
factuel scientifiques
[Musique]
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut déduire de
tout ça et ben on peut en tout premier
déduire que l'objet n'a absolument pas
l'apparence qu'il semble avoir sur ses
vidéos parce qu'à cet instant précis tu
l'as on voit très clairement que c'est
la caméra qui fait une rotation parce
que tout tourne tout sauf la forme de
l'objet un des facteurs qu'on néglige le
plus c'est le plaisir de comprendre les
choses vous parlez à un platiste il a
compris que la terre était plate alors
que vous parlez à n'importe quel jeune
il a appris à l'école que la terre était
ronde mais quand on rentre dans le
platisme en fait on a des tas de choses
à expliquer on a compris plein de choses
sur le monde et je pense qu'il y a un
problème au niveau de l'éducation en
elle-même on ne la rend pas assez
intéressantes et grisante il y a pas il
y a pas une vraie joie à comprendre que
la terre est ronde parce qu'on nous
explique pas comment on assume que la
terre était ronde fort de 130 000
followers il sème ses vidéos comme des
cailloux dont les chaussures des
complotistes et espèrent toucher un
maximum de jeunes
dans cette dans ce reportage de Samia de
chirildi on nous apprend des choses à
l'école mais on n'a pas toujours
l'impression de comprendre quand on est
à l'école et la force du complotisme
c'est qu'on a l'impression de comprendre
des choses par nous-mêmes qu'est-ce que
ça vous inspire vous qui fait de la
vulgarisation scientifique sur les
réseaux notamment je pense
qu'effectivement cette notion de
comprendre de d'avoir le mécanisme
scientifique et la recherche derrière et
pas simplement de transmettre
l'information c'est essentiel parce que
si on a juste l'information à la fin on
sait pas tout ce qui s'est passé avant
et donc on peut mettre en doute chacune
des étapes et donc c'est pour ça que
c'est important de mettre en évidence
chaque étape de la démarche scientifique
de cette réflexion derrière qui a
conduit à cette connaissance
scientifique là pour pouvoir en être
certain et que effectivement lorsqu'il y
a pas ces mécanismes là qui sont révélés
il y a le doute et donc
les théories du complot s'engouffrent
là-dedans ils vont mimer entre
guillemets ces mécanismes mais
finalement aboutir à un raisonnement qui
est erroné ou à induire en erreur la
personne et c'est ce que vous essayez de
faire du coup quand vous allez dans les
écoles ou bien lorsque vous faites des
vidéos sur YouTube comment vous procédez
justement pour essayer de faire en sorte
que toute votre démonstration soit
claire et être vraiment les personnes à
comprendre et pas simplement à apprendre
mais justement on met on met en place
cette cette démarche là quand
j'interviens dans des collèges ou dans
des lycées ou même avec des associations
on essaie de construire ensemble les
notions et pas simplement de donner
l'information d'être vraiment dans une
démarche ou ensemble avec chaque
information que chacun a on va réussir à
construire ces notions là mettre en
doute ce qui doit être mis en Doutre
essayer de comprendre d'où viennent les
informations pour construire ça et sur
sur Youtube c'est la même démarche en
mettant en avant les recherches
scientifiques mais aussi en mettant en
avant les fois ou parfois c'est pas
forcément clair parfois l'étude
scientifique a une autre étude
scientifique à montrer quelque chose qui
est différent parce que c'est aussi ça
la science donc on essaie de mettre en
évidence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais donc c'est très présent tout de
suite roman vous aussi vous êtes très
présente sur les réseaux sociaux est-ce
que vous l'observez aussi ce type de
tendance vous dans le public que vous
avez sur Tik Tok par exemple étant donné
que je parle ni de science ni de
complots je parle plus bah d'astrologie
développement personnel pardon je sais
pas quelque chose que je vais retrouver
avec mes abonnés une réticence entre
guillemets à la science c'est pas
quelque chose c'est pas un lien qui se
fait vous êtes adepte d'astrologie de de
lithothérapie on va parler de cette
tendance ensuite qui est très forte
aujourd'hui chez les jeunes et puis même
qui est très forte tout court et vous
dites ça va pas nécessairement de pair
avec une méfiance avec une défiance
envers la science en tout cas moi je
l'ai pas observé à travers mes abonnés
donc je dirais plutôt plutôt non mais ça
doit exister bien sûr mais en tout cas
je l'ai pas observé et je disais de la
lithothérapie vous vous êtes d'autres
doctorants cancérologie pour vous la
lithothérapie dans votre tête en tout
cas ça remplace ça remplace pas la
médecine quelle place à par rapport à la
médecine conventionnelle alors ça ne
rempl enfin selon moi ça remplace pas du
tout du tout la médecine enfin ça va pas
remplacer ni un médicament ni un
traitement médical ça peut être on va
dire quelque chose enfin une pierre ça
peut accompagner une guérison mais ça ne
sera pas la solution à la guérison bien
évidemment alors redirigstad il y avait
une étude de la Fondation Jean Jaurès en
début d'année elle a fait couler
beaucoup d'encre elle a montré une
véritable sécession de la jeunesse
vis-à-vis du consensus scientifique il y
avait un certain nombre de chiffres qui
avaient été très commenté dans les
médias je vais les donner par exemple
27% des jeunes sondés dans cette étude
remettaient en cause la théorie de
l'évolution il y avait 19% qui pensaient
que les pyramides ont été construite par
des aliens est-ce que selon vous
aujourd'hui on assiste à une véritable
sécession de la jeunesse vis-à-vis du
consensus scientifique écoutez c'est une
étude d'abord qui a été conçue par
l'Ifop avec la Fondation reboot laquelle
on suit la France critique exactement
à laquelle la Fondation Jaurès a été
associée par la suite pour la
publication des résultats notamment
c'est une étude qui suggère qui a un
lien effectivement entre le refus de la
rationalité scientifique le rejet de la
nationalité scientifiques et l'adhésion
aux théories du complot tout un tas
d'énoncé conspirationniste classiquement
conspirationniste c'est quelque chose
qu'on avait déjà observé là dans des
études qu'on avait commandité
Jean Jaurès où on voyait une corrélation
effectivement entre l'adhésion par
exemple à la croyance dans la voyance
dans le spiritisme dans le créationnisme
l'idée que
univers la Terre a été créée il y a
yassimilan etc avec
avec toutes sortes comme ça de dénoncer
qui relève de la pseudoscience et les
théories du complot c'est à dire que
c'était corrélé et que ça suggéré que
c'était quelque part la recherche d'une
vérité alternative qui s'exprimait là
voilà alors après on parlait de
lithothérapie ce que viennent chercher
je crois les gens beaucoup c'est l'effet
placebo et l'effet placebo
scientifiquement on sait l'identifier on
sait que ça marche ça marche on sait que
c'est notre cerveau qui fait l'essentiel
de la guérison et éventuelle bon voilà
donc et dans tout ça pour vous qu'elle
est le rôle des réseaux est-ce que c'est
la source du mal c'est un amplificateur
c'est un révélateur je donne juste
quelques chiffres sur les habitudes
médias des jeunes donc leurs habitudes
pour s'informer c'est d'abord quand même
qui privilégie leur entourage mais
ensuite il y a internet il les réseaux
sociaux bon je pense que c'est une
tendance dans toute la population
française mais il s'agit pas de
diabolisé les réseaux sociaux c'est un
instrument formidable c'est un concentré
de technologie d'intelligence et
smartphone etc donc voilà ce qui est le
grand paradoxe de notre époque c'est que
circule sur ses concentré d'intelligence
des réflexes et des pulsions parfois
complètement archaïque voilà qui relève
de la croyance dans la dans la pensée
magique
le lynchage créatif qui est consacré à
la calomnie etc on voit des choses on
s'exprimer qui sont très très anciennes
qui remontent au fond des âges et et oui
là aussi on sait que une des variables
explicatives du conspirationnisme chez
les jeunes aujourd'hui très clairement
c'est leur manière de s'informer quand
on s'informe prioritairement sur les
réseaux sociaux et encore plus sur le
plateforme de vidéo en ligne alors à
l'époque c'est moins TikTok que YouTube
mais très clairement il y a une
corrélation avec l'adhésion plus forte à
n'importe quel théorie du complot donc
on peut pas l'isoler dernier point quand
même il y a
un média indépendant russe en langue
anglaise qui a quelques mois a fait
publier une enquête sur des influenceurs
Tik Tok faire des jeunes en général qui
ont une chaîne TikTok avec beaucoup
d'abonnés et ils se sont présentés comme
étant des prestataires pour le
gouvernement russe en disant voilà on
vous propose moyennant finance de
relayer des contenus de propagande de
désinformation à cette manière assez
épaisse en plus procrement sur l'Ukraine
et bien dans la plupart des cas ils ont
eu une acceptation de la part de ses
influenceurs qui ont donc accepté d'être
payés pour relayer de la désinformation
et on sait qu'elle est très présente les
informations notamment sur TikTok donc
là il y a un problème presque d'éthique
et du déontologie lorsqu'on a des
centaines de milliers d'abonnés il y a
une loi qui est en cours d'examen
d'ailleurs qui va passer au Sénat au
niveau européen là-dessus effectivement
pour encadrer l'activité des
influenceurs qu'il s'agisse de la
désinformation qu'il s'agisse de vendre
parfois de la camelott Matteo matagora
est-ce que c'est sondages que l'on a
qu'on vient de développer il vous
inquiète aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
vous inquiétez aujourd'hui d'une
sécession des jeunes ou des Français
vis-à-vis de des sciences alors je crois
qu'il faut rester très alerte il faut
rester très très attentif à ce qui se
passe de ce point de vue là les
complétisme existe et et
une certaine tendance à se faire piéger
comme on l'a vu très bien dans dans les
premières dans les premières vidéos
existent
à une version déjà on connaît les
publics parce qu'on le voit venir mais
c'est pas un échantillon représentatif
et on a lancé par les sciences
et
on a lancé ces baromètres de l'esprit
critique qui est un autre sondage qui
est un peu plus proche de la plupart des
sondages qui se différencient un peu de
Jean Jaurès ou pour moi un attachement
des Français aux sciences
il y a une sorte de tendance à dire bon
les les Français ou les européennes ou
ont une certaine défiance pour les
sciences etc en effet non
largement c'est une des catégories les
chercheurs les scientifiques qui est
plus dignes de confiance pour les gens
peut-être c'est pas très gentil de le
dire ici sur cette chaîne mais si on
regarde la confiance dans les
différentes institutions
et et même les journalistes
aussi donc on voit qu'il y a un vrai
problème pour les médias d'avoir une
parole qui semble légitime pour pour les
gens il y a une défiance de jeunes
vis-à-vis des institutions ça c'est vrai
la science s'en sort plutôt bien dans
ces cadres ça reste quelque chose
d'assez vu positivement par les jeunes
surtout le climat exactement il faut pas
une des choses que les chercheurs nous
disent c'est de faire attention à mettre
les sciences tout dans le même panier on
voit que les jeunes sont qui ont une
vraie préoccupation pour les questions
climatiques on a aussi envie de faire
confiance aux chercheurs sur la question
climatique sur d'autres questions que
peut-être on peut voir avec une certaine
légèreté et on peut ne pas trop se
préoccuper si c'est vrai ou faux pourvu
que ça soit contre l'institution une
attitude assez classique sur les jeunes
là alors ils peuvent s'exprimer contre
les sciences mais on voit que sur les
choses qui les retiennent à cœur et la
parole scientifique une parole qui est
qui est reconnue comme intéressante et
le climat vous montre il prend leur
temps pour aller marcher pour les
climats donc c'est pas rien alors on
parlait un des liens entre des sciences
scientifiques et complotisme douter de
tout et même penser que tout ce qui nous
est dit dans des canaux traditionnels
par exemple dans des médias est faux et
bien c'est le propre du complotisme face
à cela les jeunes sont d'autant plus
vulnérables que beaucoup pensent que le
nombre d'abonnés d'un influenceur et
gage de vérité et maître Gims lui a 3
millions d'abonnés sur Twitter il y en a
11 millions sur facebook autant sur
Youtube et voilà ce qu'il a dit il y a
quelques jours
[Musique]
à l'époque de l'empire de couches il y
avait l'électricité mais pyramides qu'on
voit là
au sommet il y a de l'or c'est le
meilleur conducteur pour l'électricité
c'était des foutuses antennes les gens
les gens veulent l'électricité les gens
ils arrivent pas à comprendre ça les
Égyptiens la science qu'ils avaient ça
dépasse l'entendement et nous sommes à
présent avec la journaliste haute Favre
qui est présidente de l'association
fakeup vous tenez aussi la chaîne
Youtube Aude what the fuck bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous au-dessus
cette vidéo et ça viralité sont pour
vous inquiétantes cette vidéo de Gims
puisque j'ai dit maître Gims par
expérience
c'est vrai c'est vrai que souvent des
Gims dans les dans les dents dans les
classes bah écoutez oui t'inquiétant
j'ai enfin
en fait ce qui est ce qui est ce qui est
difficile parfois d'expliquer un certain
nombre de jeunes mais je veux pas les
pointer plus que les que les que les
moins jeunes qui sont pas non plus voilà
qui auprès desquels il y a un certain
travail à faire aussi mais c'est vrai
que on observe de temps en temps avec
l'association fécov notamment quand on
va dans les classes une certaine forme
de de relativisme c'est à dire que moi
j'ai eu plusieurs fois des jeunes qui me
qui me disaient mais finalement
qu'est-ce qu'on s'en fiche enfin je veux
dire alors je veux pas généraliser parce
que c'est pas du tout la plupart et puis
en ce qui pense vraiment on sait pas
mais en tout cas j'ai eu de temps en
temps cette idée que c'était pas grave
quoi enfin je veux dire ça va et et
souvent assez donné par ce genre de de
commentaires et là typiquement je sais
que cette vidéo elle tourne dans notre
petit cercle de enfin grand cercle de
journaliste on est près de 80
journalistes aujourd'hui à fécov pour
pour savoir me vendre des vidéos comme
ça on en a toutes les semaines qu'on
s'échange entre nous pour pour essayer
de voir comment voilà par quel bout
prendre les choses c'est vrai que le
fact checking est intéressant donc dès
qu'on peut on va aux sources on essaie
de voilà bref de travailler avec eux de
les mettre dans la peau de de
journaliste après on n'a pas on n'a pas
toujours le temps mais c'est vrai que
nous ce qu'on essaye de de parfois
d'expliquer de manière assez large c'est
que
c'est de prendre le problème c'est pas à
l'envers mais je veux dire par le bout
c'est à dire qu'il y a toujours des
conséquences finalement à la
désinformation et on essaye aussi parce
que ça c'est un c'est quelque chose qui
leur parle alors là c'est les pyramides
bon on pourrait en trouver c'est sûr
mais
il y a toujours des que ce soit des gens
des organismes ou des des
quelque chose qui trinque au bout de ça
et ça je sais qu'ils sont assez
réceptifs à ça juste petit
aparté sur les pyramides on a RMC
découverte qui depuis un certain temps
diffuse très très régulièrement un
documenté scientifique notoire qui
s'appelle la révélation des pyramides et
c'est vrai que ça on me l'a déjà pointé
aussi dans des collèges
ça interroge sur aussi le rôle des
médias
bah oui alors quand j'en parle à RMC
j'ai des collègues à RMC ah oui mais RMC
découverte c'est un autre département
j'ai pas encore fait tout investigation
le voit pas forcément restez avec nous
au de parce que si vous êtes si vous
avez dit sur un petit peu le relativisme
ça me marque aussi par rapport à des
choses que vous nous avez dit en
pré-interview Gael c'est que vous parlez
d'un certain vous fatalisme que vous
observiez démon de toute façon ou tout
ça c'est pas grave un peu on va de toute
façon on va tous mourir donc c'est pas
grave enfin c'est un peu ce genre de
tout à fait que vous avez aussi parfois
tout à fait sur c'est surtout quelque
chose que je rencontre sur Tik Tok et ça
m'a beaucoup surpris au début ça
m'arrive donc de faire des vidéos sur
des thématiques de santé et de médecine
et d'avoir des situations dans
lesquelles on me dit mais de toute façon
peu importe je vais mourir au travail à
50 ans et de voir des commentaires tel
quel écrit comme ça et ça m'a beaucoup
étonné d'avoir ce devoir vraiment se
fatalisme et cette de toute façon ça
change rien et comme disait le faire de
que ça soit vrai ou faux finalement on
s'en fiche ça changera rien notre
quotidien à notre vie oui donc c'est
quelque chose de très présent qu'on
observe en tout cas quand on est en
contact avec les plus jeunes hautes pour
revenir à vous comment les médias selon
vous peuvent aider à lutter contre les
discours complotistes quand déjà ils
n'en diffuse pas sur leur chaîne comment
comment est-ce qu'il est comment est-ce
qu'il peut faire sachant que c'est ce
que vous disiez Matteo matagora c'est
que les médias les journalistes
aujourd'hui inspirent peu confiance au
public donc on a quand même un vrai
problème aussi d'image du côté des
médias
je pense que c'est un problème aussi
enfin moi j'ai le souvenir il y a
quelques années c'est pas si vieux où je
proposais à la rédaction finalement de
raconter les coulisses mais c'était il y
a je dirais pas si vieux il y a
peut-être 10 ans quoi et vraiment tout
le monde dans la rédac me regarder en
disant mais qui est-ce que ça peut
intéresser enfin je veux dire c'est
vraiment enfin c'est vraiment c'était
vraiment l'idée la pire idée de l'année
quoi c'est n'importe quoi j'étais là bah
je sais pas en même temps il se passe un
truc c'est hyper compliqué on se fait
jeter à droite j'étais à gauche on
essaie de choper des infos comme on peut
etc et on voit maintenant que finalement
je sais plus le nombre de je sais pas de
projets dans ce sens de ouverture du
journaliste a fait l'enquête etc et je
pense que ça fait partie aussi de enfin
donc moi je prône beaucoup ça c'est à
dire le fait de évidemment de d'obtenir
le journaliste au plus grand nombre
c'est ce que je fais d'une série
documentaires là on a un serveur discord
et on a plus d'un millier de personnes
qui vont faire des enquêtes avec moi en
l'occurrence là c'est vraiment c'est
génial parce que je me retrouve pas
enquêter avec eux des assistants
maternels
mais au-delà de ça même voilà une petite
échelle je pense que il faut
qu'on a enfin comment dire je sais que
c'est un métier très qui prend beaucoup
de temps etc mais il faut vraiment
poser le micro et aller auprès des gens
à la rencontre quoi initiale un dialogue
moi je pense que vraiment la
désinformation on peut essayer d'armer
les gens leur dire regarde source fait
ceci fait cela mais si on répare pas
quelque part ce ce
problème de défiance entre les citoyens
et journalistes je crois pas comment on
peut s'en sortir et donc c'est vrai que
moi de plus en plus je
dans ce dans ce sens là et c'est ce
qu'on essaye de faire à fécoff en
essayant d'aller dans effectivement dans
le maximum de classe dialoguer discuter
on fait tomber beaucoup de barrières
vous savez des fois rien qu'on veut en
s'asseyant auprès des élèves on leur
demandant de découvrir leur explique pas
ça j'ai pas compris est-ce que c'est
vrai ce que c'est faux bah viens on va
t'aider des fois ça tient qu'à ça en
fait et donc je suis assez voilà assez
assez confiante mais c'est vrai qu'il
faut que ce soit massif quoi et bien
merci merci beaucoup d'être intervenu
dans cette émission et vous travaillez
donc à une série de documentaire donc
vous n'êtes pas là c'est en
collaboration avec des citoyens et ça
sera diffusé sur Arte on suivra ça avec
beaucoup d'attention redire eichtat
j'en reviens au site ce qui est
intéressant peut-être si c'est de
comprendre le mécanisme du complotisme
qui sont les personnes qui sont les plus
friandes de théorie du complot c'est une
des choses dont vous parlez aussi dans
votre livre écoutez on dispose de de
quelques variables sociaux économiques
démographique qui nous permet d'avoir
une sorte de portrait robot encore que
ce serait très réducteur de dire tous
les gens qui sont sensibles à ça sont
comme ça etc globalement le niveau de
diplôme a tendance à protéger contre un
niveau de conspirationnisme plus plus
affirmé le niveau de vie aussi
l'idée que lorsqu'on a le sentiment
d'avoir raté sa vie par exemple on est
plus perméable aux idées
conspirationnistes lorsque politiquement
se situe aux deux extrémités du spectre
politique et notamment l'extrême droite
c'est encore plus vrai à l'extrême
droite on est plus perméable à ces idées
là
voilà quelques-unes des pieds évidemment
ce que je disais tout à l'heure les
manières de s'informer ça va de pair
avec les réseaux sociaux les plateformes
de vidéos et du coup romane vous le
disiez vous qui êtes très suivi sur les
réseaux sociaux vous faites face aussi à
ce type de public et vous dites il y a
une véritable responsabilité aussi
lorsqu'on part sur les réseaux sociaux
qu'on est très suivi parce que très
souvent on est pris au pied de la lettre
quand on s'exprime bah je pense que on a
tous une responsabilité quand on
s'exprime sur les réseaux sociaux mais
effectivement plus on a d'audience plus
on doit faire attention à ce qu'on dit
effectivement ça peut plus être plus
vite être pris
de la lettre par les plus jeunes donc
oui on a une responsabilité avant mais
il faut trouver un équilibre
pour ne pas se brimer pour ne pas se
brider non plus et en même temps partagé
ce qu'on aime tant que ça reste dans la
bienveillance et que ça peut pas mener à
des dérives etc mais oui mais une
véritable responsabilité
sur les bien sûr aujourd'hui c'est
important peut-être il faudrait aussi
une décharte à respecter faire attention
aux historiés favorable oui oui j'y
serai favorable parce que je crois que
ça existe déjà il y a certains
influenceurs qui ont des
certifications entre guillemets des
labels donc oui oui parce que pour
l'instant c'est le Far West oui c'est ça
l'image d'internet c'est c'est pas très
régulé quoi
Mathéo matagora qu'est-ce qui fait qu'on
passe pour vous d'un doute fécond parce
qu'on l'a dit parfois le doute les
oppositions c'est les gens qui sont pas
d'accord c'est nécessaire pour pouvoir
construire son esprit critique un doute
total et la remise en cause de tout et
qui fait peut-être c'est l'une des
caractéristiques de du complotisme oui
j'aime beaucoup la façon dont vous posez
la question parce que l'esprit critique
c'est justement ce n'est pas assez
méfier de tous ce n'est pas croire à
tous et bien placé la confiance parce
que parfois on peut pas revérifier tous
ce qu'on fait donc bien la placer alors
qu'est-ce que fait que on arrive à
placer mal la confiance je pense que
très souvent ça n'a rien à voir avec
la vérité de ses compagnes ça avoir
beaucoup plus avec ces situations de
désarroi des difficultés des besoins de
faire communauté les platistes sont pas
des gens qui sont intéressés à la forme
de la terre il ferait autre chose sans
des gens qui sont intéressés à
construire une communauté autour d'une
croyance il construit cette communauté
il se retrouve bien ensemble et donc
peu importe la forme de la terre en gros
une fois qu'on s'est rassemble autour
d'une idée et donc c'est c'est souvent
ces situations et nous c'est que je
pense sur quoi on doit vraiment
travailler c'est sur la formation du
culture des bases diffusée continue à
l'esprit critique c'est-à-dire à
toujours se demander le disait aussi
l'interviewé belge au début et comment
est-ce qu'on sait ces conseils comment
c'est arrivé jusqu'à nous et c'est
l'éducation aux médias comment on a
produit cette connaissance et c'est la
méthode scientifique comment on
l'intègre à notre à nos actions
successives et c'est un peu le balance
qu'on fait parfois sur certains choses
comme vous le disiez très très justement
une pierre ça va très bien mais pour
d'autres choses un cancer ou autre non
il faut surtout pas
que des lieux comme le musée des
sciences universitaires mais aussi tous
les autres on a une exposition esprit
critique à ces moments qui étaient à
Toulouse maintenant un Bretagne qui va
arriver à Paris bientôt et justement
pour développer cette connaissance du
fait que il faut interroger la
connaissance à chaque fois savoir à
quelle affaire confiance et pourquoi
c'est un point absolument crucial c'est
à dire qu'il faut Ré commenter la
science parce que précisément si on veut
concurrencer les croyances
irrationnelles le complotisme ou autre
les croyances dangereuses surtout et
bien il faut prendre en compte le fait
que si elle se diffuse c'est grâce à cet
effet de dévoilement l'effet de
dévoilement des théories du complot les
vidéos complotistes c'est on va vous
dire la vérité sur c'est ce qui fait
leur succès c'est on va vous montrer
quelque chose d'un côté vous pensez en
situation un peu héroïque de celui qui a
compris le sous des cartes qui voient
plus loin que les autres à qui on l'a
fait Pâques et plus malin que les autres
et puis il y a cet effet de dévoilement
qui est assez comparable à celui qu'on
peut éprouver quand on regarde un film
je suis pas policier ou d'espionnage et
qu'à la fin bon du tout final tout se
met en place et on a l'impression
d'avoir compris ce que vous disiez tout
à l'heure et c'est où ce que disait
Samuel bustré tout à l'heure dans le
reportage
d'un couplement c'est très satisfaisant
pour l'esprit c'est très c'est un
plaisir intellectuel cognitif comme tous
les plaisirs on a envie de le renouveler
et donc il faut que la science devienne
au moins aussi attractive paradoxie
paradoxalement justement en fait quand
on fait la science et qu'on comprend les
qu'on travaille sur les mécanismes
derrière c'est exactement cette
sensation de dévoiement mais
effectivement il faut la réussir à la
réenchanter parce qu'elle existe déjà
tellement à la canaliser à ce que le
grand public est nous tous et toutes on
soit consciente de la réalité derrière
ça et donc de lever le capot que ça soit
pour le journalisme ou pour la recherche
et la science lever le capot sur comment
est-ce que ça fonctionne et comment
est-ce qu'on en arrive à ces
informations là cette connaissance
Gaëlle on sort aussi d'une grande
période de crise bien sûr qu'on a tous
vécu c'est celle du covid un grand
moment où on a eu et bien beaucoup de
caresses scientifiques voire de remise
en cause de la parole scientifique voire
de dévoiement de la parole scientifique
vous est-ce que vous avez observé un
impact de toute cette crise aujourd'hui
sur vos proches ou sur les gens que vous
côtoyaient en faisant de la
vulgarisation scientifique en fait ce
qui m'a moi ce qui m'a surpris pendant
la crise du covid et là en fait il y a
le il y a le problème de
une situation nouvelle et donc la
science se faisait en même temps que la
société avançait donc c'est compliqué
puisque la science demande du recul on
en parlait tout à l'heure avec le doute
avec la question d'esprit critique de il
y a des études qui sont faites tout ça
prend du temps et tant qu'il y a pas ses
réponses là on reste dans ce doute et
donc faut réussir à
montrer à ce que la société comprenne la
situation dans laquelle on est où est-ce
qu'il m'a surpris c'est qu'en fait je me
suis rendu compte que sur que ça soit
ces questions là ou sur d'autres
questions finalement il y a beaucoup de
choses qu'on ignore et que on va pas
chercher à comprendre justement on se
pose la question là finalement personne
ne connaissait les vaccins ARN messagers
et du jour au lendemain on a commencé à
s'intéresser au sujet donc c'est à la
fois des opportunités aussi des risques
des situations dans lesquelles puisque
le grand public puisqu'on n'a pas les
réponses à ces questions n'importe qui
qui va nous amener cette une possible
réponse potentiellement il y a des
mécanismes théories de complot on va
s'en satisfaire et notre esprit critique
va peut-être être un peu moins au
travail
alors on a parlé au jeu de la défiance
envers les sciences de un certain essor
du complotisme on va aussi bien parler
d'une autre tendance qu'on observe
aujourd'hui en parallèle un grand
intérêt aujourd'hui pour les parasiences
pour les autorismes pour l'astrologie
alors est-ce ou non le corollaire de
cette défiance envers les sciences on va
on discuter sur ce plateau mais d'abord
on va parler de cette grande vogue de
locultisme sur les réseaux sociaux avec
Audrey
[Musique]
et Audrey et bien vous avez un chiffre
très parlant sur ce sujet 12 millions
c'est le nombre de résultats qu'on
trouve quand on tape le hashtag astro
sur TikTok le réseau social qui attire
le plus les jeunes et les chiffres
s'affolent aussi quand on tape tarot
sorcellerie voyance les déclinaisons de
tout ce qui touche à l'ésotérisme facile
des tendances pour certaines vieilles
comme le monde l'astrologie oui mais
cette fois-ci on les trouve sur TikTok
en version 3.0 avec des vidéos courtes
de moins d'une minute pour savoir par
exemple quelle signe astrologique
s'attire le plus ou encore l'influence
des signes du zodiaque sur les
personnalités je vous propose de
regarder un cours extrait d'une
publication du compte Astro Zodiac
dois-je laisser tomber ou pas amour
durable et bien cela concerne quoi qu'il
en soit une personne dont tuer amoureux
ou amoureuse maintenant est-ce que ces
sentiments sont réciproques c'est ce que
nous allons voir dans la suite de ce
tirage et si tu dois laisser tomber la
faire ou pas nous avons la carte ok de
l'abondance tu es très heureux ou
heureuse dans tous les autres domaines
de ta vie j'ai l'impression actuellement
les finances se portent bien au travail
aussi et bien tout se passe bien voilà
etc etc mais j'ai l'impression que du
côté de l'amour tu as encore des doutes
j'ai encore un chiffre pour compléter
toujours selon l'étude Ifop 49% des
jeunes de 18 à 24 ans estiment que
l'astrologie est une science c'est 6
points de plus qu'en
1999 était aussi proportionnelle avec la
fréquence de consultation du réseau
social TikTok et est-ce qu'on sait d'où
vient cette tendance chez les plus
jeunes alors quand on écoute les
témoignages beaucoup évoquent un déclic
avec la crise sanitaire et le
confinement d'ailleurs à cette période
les ventes de la maison d'édition
alliance magique qui est visualiser dans
les la littérature ésotérique c'est
vente elles ont augmenté de 70% par
rapport à 2019 l'année précédente
l'astrologie la voyance la sorcellerie
serait des moyens de se rassurer
finalement quand l'avenir est un certain
c'est vrai qu'on peut le comprendre
quand on sait pas de quoi demain sera
fait c'est un côté rassurant finalement
de savoir un peu l'avenir en fin d'en
avoir une idée et puis il y a aussi une
approche plus naturaliste qui s'inscrit
dans une logique écologique l'ésotérisme
incarnent un retour à la nature à
travers des pratiques ancestrales et
puis la sorcière peut aussi incarner une
figure féministe forte ce sont des
termes des termes pardon qui touchent en
général les plus jeunes quelques
chiffres enfin parce que j'aime bien les
chiffres 38% des 18 24 ans disent croire
aux prédictions dévoyantes et 36% aux
envoutements et à la sorcellerie merci
merci pour tous ces chiffres et ces
explications Audrey roman et bien on a
entendu avec ce que nous disait Audrey
bien la place qui avait eu par exemple
le covid pour pour les jeunes pour leur
intérêt pour l'ésotérisme et
l'astrologie vous comment est-ce que ça
vous est venu
l'intérêt pour l'astrologie
je dirais que c'était quand j'avais 15
ans au moment de l'adolescence souvent
c'est une période où on a envie de mieux
se connaître on a envie de on est un peu
dans une quête de soi-même et quand j'ai
découvert l'astrologie ça m'a permis de
mieux me comprendre de mieux comprendre
les autres de mieux comprendre les
relations qu'on pouvait aussi avoir avec
les autres et
concrètement quand vous rencontrez une
personne vous lui demandez toujours son
signe astrologique c'est quelque chose
qui est et vous faites tout de suite des
liens avec cette personnalité vous
analysez qu'est-ce que vous analysez
avec ça dans ma tête oui je vais me
faire des petits pronostics quoi sur le
signe de la personne après je veux quand
je rencontre quelqu'un je dis pas tout
de suite quel est ton signe astrologique
mais oui ça enfin je vais me poser cette
question mais c'est pas parce que par
exemple ce signe là je l'aime moins bien
qu'un autre signe que je vais pas
apprendre à connaître cette personne ou
que je vais catégoriser directement la
personne enfin faut savoir aussi
mais des distances avec avec
l'astrologie aussi enfin ivoire comme un
plus mais ça doit pas définir nos
relations et nos vies entièrement est-ce
que vous avez observé ce boom de
l'astrologie dont on parle et chez les
jeunes sur TikTok comment est-ce que ça
s'est passé est-ce que vous l'avez vu
sur votre nombre d'abonnés les personnes
qui vous suivent je vous avais quand
même près de 700 000 abonnés sur TikTok
c'est quand même vraiment très important
après je parle pas que d'astrologie sur
mon compte Tik Tok mais effectivement
les vidéos là où j'ai le plus de vues
c'est vraiment les les vidéos sur
l'astrologie ça peut aller à plusieurs
millions de vues juste pour une vidéo
qui parle d'astrologie donc oui il y a
un réel intérêt même en commentaire il y
a beaucoup d'interactions entre entre
amis les gens se mentionnent oui il y a
quand même un plus grand intérêt je
dirais que peut-être à mon époque enfin
j'étais plus jeune quoi Gaëlle vous
observez ça vous autour de vous ou pas
vous avez des amis qui sont qui vont
faire beaucoup
on en discutant moi avec des gens autour
de moi j'ai pas des amis des amis qui
allaient s'intéresser au pouvoir des
pierres etc je le enfin oui je l'ai je
l'ai découvert alors sur ce qui est
lithothérapie oui astrologie non mais
lithothérapie oui effectivement et après
moi je suis fondamentalement sceptique
sur ces questions qui me qui me
regardent après sur sur ces sujets là ce
que c'est après la question que ça pose
finalement c'est à quel moment est-ce
que c'est un loisir et effectivement on
en parlait tout à l'heure l'astrologie
ça a existé depuis très très longtemps
donc à quel moment est-ce que c'est
simplement une un loisir et à quel
moment est-ce que ça pose un réel
problème à quel moment est-ce que ça
glisse vers des théories du complot à
quel moment ça met en danger la vie des
personnes c'est tout un ensemble de
questions après sur ces sujets là oui
deux choses je crois que il y a une
fonction sociale des pseudosciences ou
de l'astrologie qui est capable
d'ailleurs à la fonction sociale du
complotisme c'est-à-dire que ça met une
illusion de maîtrise sur de lit
maîtrisable vous savez l'idée que le
monde n'est que chaotique qui n'a aucun
sens et qu'il est absurde et une idée
angoissante l'idée qu'un pilote dans
l'avion qu'on les appelle les Illuminati
ou les Américains la CIA ou les Sages de
Sion quelque part ça donne l'illusion de
retrouver une forme de maîtrise de
domination sur les choses d'accord
oui bien sûr la Providence en fait c'est
ça le complotisme
etc bien sûr donc je pense que c'est ça
qu'on vient aussi chercher c'est-à-dire
de la maîtrise de quelque chose qui
n'est pas maîtrisable mais le versant
inquiétant de cela c'est que le temps
qu'on consacre aux théories du complot
fake news et des informations aux
croyances
pas établi scientifiquement c'est du
temps qui est limité c'est du temps de
l'attention que nous n'avons pas de
manière illimitée et donc le temps que
nous accordons à ces choses là et du
temps qui est pris par exemple en
matière de fake news sur la bonne
information d'accord à haute valeur
ajoutée c'est du temps qui est pris sur
la connaissance scientifiquement validée
et ça ça c'est inquiétant parce que
si ces choses-là prennent trop
d'importance trop de place qu'elles
sortent de leur dimension récréative et
bien c'est à la fin des fins c'est la
démocratie qui est en danger vous allez
jusque là bien sûr est-ce que vous ça
vous inquiète aussi du coup cet essor
des des parasians de ce type de croyance
et est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
ça peut prendre le pas sur la science
que voilà ce qu'il faut opposer l'un et
l'autre
je crois que je suis très d'accord avec
ce qui a été dit en soi c'est une
question de mesures vraiment de mes de
mesures de à quel point on arrive à
maîtriser et à mettre dans la bonne case
certains comportements et dans la case
par contre d'attention d'autres
comportements nous on essaie de de
l'université par exemple des traités
quand même ces questions aujourd'hui aux
étincelles du Palais de la découverte et
le lieu et un lieu de médiation ou on
parle des cristaux et on essaie de voir
avec l'approche esprit critique
qu'est-ce qu'on peut savoir sur
l'efficacité de la lithothérapie là
encore c'est pas une question de dire
c'est bien c'est mal c'est une question
de dire quelle question on peut poser
pour vérifier si ça correspond à nos
attentes et évidemment lesquels sont
déduisez par exemple enfin je sur la
lithothérapie
du point de vue scientifique il y a rien
qui peut te montrer une quoi conque
efficacité de ce type d'activité par
contre on peut voir qu'il un bien-être
qui se construit autour de cette
pratique
du développement personnel lorsque vous
parlez de la lithothérapie ou de
l'astrologie oui je pense que ça va pas
sans l'autre on peut pas donner tout le
pouvoir à une pierre aussi travailler
sur soi à côté après je suis il y a
peut-être l'effet placebo mais c'est
vrai que je pense qu'il y a aussi
peut-être une dimension un peu plus
spirituelle peut-être avec les pierres
et du coup que la mais c'est pas de la
science en tout cas c'est pas vérifiable
tout de suite nous sommes en relation
également avec abdouk daba bonjour vous
êtes philosophe anthropologue ethnologue
fondateur du sociologue merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous vous comment est-ce que
vous interprétez ce goût pour les
parasiens si le cultisme aujourd'hui et
peut-être aussi par le passé parce que
c'est peut-être plus visible aujourd'hui
mais je pense que ça a toujours existé
on est assez d'accord sur ce plateau là
dessus
exactement anthropologiquement on sait
très bien que sapiens c'est un mythomane
ça tient est un être de fiction et se
raconte des histoires et quand ces
histoires sont partagées alors il peut
faire communauté il peut organiser une
société si vous prenez l'économie
aujourd'hui c'est fondé sur un système
de confiance sur sur un mythe le mythe
que tel pays votant parce que on a
établi des critères auxquels tout le
monde adhère essayez de donner un billet
de 20 euros à un chimpanzé il en voudra
pas il comprendra même pas la valeur que
que vous lui donnerez donc les parasiens
ou plus globalement toutes les croyances
ont effectivement toujours existé parce
qu'elles ont un besoin vous l'avez déjà
rappelé c'est le besoin de mettre de
l'ordre dans le monde et de trouver sa
place si on a l'impression que nous ne
sommes qu'une petite poussière d'étoile
perdue au fin fond d'une planète
elle-même perdue au fin fond d'une
galaxie qui est perdue dans un espace
qu'on n'arrive même plus à mesurer le
sinon d'angoisse est-elle qu'il est
couplé avec celui de l'absurdité donc
les croyances et toutes les pratiques
dont vous avez parlé jusqu'à présent
servent à
conjurer cette angoisse et à se dire que
peut-être quelque part il y a une vérité
c'est ça il y a une vérité et ce désir
de vérité fait que on va essayer de
suivre une pratique alors qu'est-ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui pourquoi pourquoi
c'est important pourquoi ça explosé
s'explosait parce que la pandémie ni
plus ni moins concernée on n'a jamais
été aussi perdu que pendant la pandémie
de covid on a peut-être jamais eu autant
besoin de cette étincelle que pendant
cette période et encore peut-être
aujourd'hui et maintenant qu'on en subit
les conséquences
la planète entière a été enfermée chez
elle avec
l'opportunité disons-le comme ça de se
poser des questions qu'on met
généralement sous le tapis ou qu'on
laisse aux philosophe au physicien
quantique les ou religieux les questions
métaphysiques qui suis-je qu'est-ce que
je fais là quel est le sens de ma vie
donc enfermé
on a été coupé du lien de cause à effet
qui nous permettait de nous valoriser
dans une certaine fonction et dans
certaines habitudes c'est un peu comme
si on avait arrêté la roue du hamster on
s'est déconditionné et à partir de là
toutes les questions métaphysiques et
les questions sur la vie sur la mort
sont survenus et il est pas étonnant que
chacun est ici ou là essayer de trouver
une solution et comme vous l'avez
rappelé un espèce de sentiment de
maîtrise ça va passer par la cartomancie
ça va passer par par le complotisme en
tout cas c'est cette idée de cette
fameuse idée du pilote dans l'avion en
fait qu'est-ce qu'on essaye de faire on
essaie de trouver ça propre vérité qu'on
va partager avec une communauté pour
créer un chez soi idéologique la
déchéance vous n'avez cessé de le
rappeler la défiance est-elle que le
discours politique et le discours
scientifique
paraissent inféodé à un système qui est
un système capitaliste disons le tel
quel ou le seul intérêt du profit pour
une petite minorité fait que l'ensemble
des des membres de la communauté et
bafoué à partir de là l'esprit critique
va essayer d'attraper de nouveaux outils
pour les mettre dans un certain ordre et
grâce aux algorithmes mais grâce aux
réseaux sociaux trouver une communauté
qui va valider merci merci beaucoup
Abdou Gnaba pour toute aux explications
et toute votre interprétation de ces
phénomènes vous avez parlé du fait que
et bien le complotisme c'était aussi
faire communauté vous vous avez les fait
les frais de cette communauté Rudy
Reichstadt parce que vous racontez
encore dans votre livre au cœur du
complot comment ça s'est manifester
des effets très très classiques de meute
en fait et de lynchage en ligne avec des
campagnes de calomnies d'une violence
dont on a pas idée si l'on n'y est pas
exposé mais paradoxalement c'est un peu
observation assez privilégié d'être pris
pour si par la théorie du complot de
devenir un objet de fantasme
conspirationniste parce que du coup nous
on sait qu'on fait pas partie d'un
complot on est les mieux placés pour le
savoir donc ça nous renseigne aussi sur
le concrétisme intimement oui et surtout
de l'esprit du complotiste qui pourquoi
est-ce qu'il vous accuse
de devenir soi-même une sorte de bouc
émissaire comme ça de figure diabolique
quoi et est-ce que vous à votre échelle
c'est des choses que vous expérimentez
parfois quand vous avez des commentaires
peut-être sur le type sur les vidéos que
vous faites ce genre de choses est-ce
que vous vous observez ce genre de chose
au moins des critiques mais j'imagine
que vous faites pas de vous faites
partie d'un complot
des critiques oui après c'est surtout
des critiques d'un point de vue enfin
c'est critiques constructives sur la
façon de présenter les choses sur la
forme
j'ai pas été la cible de théorie du
complot ou de complotistes en tout cas
pour l'instant
ça viendra peut-être avec la notoriété
après cette cette émission
vous m'avez Agora qu'est-ce que est-ce
que vous vous travaillez aussi là-dessus
à universion sur le le ressorts du
complotisme comment ça fonctionne cette
fonction de communauté on leur a compris
et puis qui peut-être a été encore plus
fort après le covid
on essaie de travailler plutôt sur les
fonds c'est pas notre corps de métier je
crois qu'il y a d'autres qui sont mieux
placés pour adresser les complotismes
comme un sujet de
d'activité on essaie de le comprendre et
voilà avec nos études et celles qu'on
qu'on que les autres les autres
chercheurs ont fait et on essaye
vraiment de travailler sur tous les ces
petites facteurs cette petite façon de
se mettre en relation avec la réalité en
lanchantant du côté en
présentant des protocoles de façon de
regarder le monde qui peuvent et
effectivement brisé on espère cette
corrélation entre une façon de de
appréhender les mondes et donc une
certaine exercice des rationalité et les
dérives complotistes donc on espère de
agir sur cette sur cette diminuer la
probabilité de cette transition tout à
l'heure quand
nous nous parlait il nous a dit
finalement effectivement c'est c'est un
peu vieux comme le monde cette nécessité
de d'être d'expliquer le monde par
quelque chose de plus grand que soi
est-ce que c'est quelque chose aussi
vous que vous ressentez que vous
ressentez aujourd'hui dans la période de
crise que nous que nous traversons au
niveau on l'a vu sanitaire notamment
pour moi c'est pas forcément une façon
de comprendre le monde comme je vous
l'ai dit tout à l'heure je pense que
c'est plus une façon de se comprendre
nous-mêmes encore une fois les relations
avec les autres moi je suis pas très
partisane de l'horoscope
de déterminer sa vie etc mais plus avant
de mieux bas de mieux se comprendre de
de une certaine quête de soi mais pour
comprendre le monde bah il y a peut-être
la science qui est justement là pour ça
et je pense que c'est deux univers assez
opposés oui qu'est-ce que vous inspire
ça finalement ce type de discours de
dire que on peut dissocier les deux et
puis aussi les associer pour pour que ça
puisse aider d'un point de vue personnel
et puis tout à fait mettre la science à
sa place je sens que tout à l'heure
quand je vous ai dit que c'est un
problème une phiné de démocratie mais je
vais je vais essayer de développer
pourquoi parce que je crois que la
superstition quotidienne les petits
gestes superstitieux qu'on peut tous
avoir ça fait pas de mal ça fait de mal
à personne le problème c'est que lorsque
la superstition a gouverné nos vies et
nos destins pendant des semaines ça
devient oui et surtout ça conduit à
prendre des mauvaises décisions lorsque
face à une épidémie ont tué des gens
lorsqu'on brûlait des sorcières
c'était des conséquences directes voilà
excusez-moi pour bien merci merci
beaucoup à tous les cas d'avoir
tromper à ce débat et en clin d'oeil
sachez que nous sommes à la veille d'une
nouvelle lune d'une éclipse solaire puis
il y aura une rétrogradation de mercure
espérons que cela ne vous aura permis de
faire cette émission sous les meilleurs
hospices merci à tous les quatre pour se
des varia très vite pour un nouveau
numéro d'avoir 20 ans
[Musique]